foreign
can you just talk about what your Early
Childhood was like and and who your
family were yeah but I mean I was
brought by a great family
we were living in fitzrovia my mum was a
Catholic my dad was great thought Greek
authored the Orthodox but he left my mum
to bring us up to what church she wanted
to and um so from there we moved up at
the East End
now the East End is a totally different
culture
to fit in
where did I fit in
I fitted in with all the kind of wrong
people
the bad boys
and we form little things and we
go around Nick and lead or something
else like that my mother and father
never knew nothing about that
in fact they didn't even know I never
went to school
because I was bunking off all the time
and I just went down the drain I started
make sure when the wrong kids got in a
fight it's got in
arguments and different things but the
thing was I learned to stand up for
myself there because you know a young
guy I tried to take my brother Tony
uh you know and give a bash in and I got
stuck into him and all the other kids
Behind themselves from now onwards and I
saw that you know violence was a way of
controlling situations
and uh it became kind of a way of life
and it was one prison sentence after
another got done for blind safes got got
done for violence got done for many
other things so it was in and out of
prison
and I worked with a little firm
from out of West London and they were in
the safe line
so we get the general night and we go in
post office or wherever and blood is
safe
then
unfortunately uh I got involved with a
craze
Ally actually met the craze was I
arranged to meet a guy called Cornelius
Whitehead and I went down there to meet
him and he didn't turn up Ronnie Bender
The Craze driver drove by he said Chris
what are you doing now I said would like
to meet somebody at the blind bagel and
answer and up and I'm catching a bus
because my car's in the garage camera he
said I'll give you a lift he said the
twins want to meet you I said look
I don't want to meet him thanks
you know I'm okay if you need a few quid
I'll help you out but I don't
particularly want to meet them he said
Chrissy said Tony's down there my
brother
I had to go
so when I go down there they were
perfect gentlemen
spoke to me said Chris we're opening the
club in Leicester where my brother's
child is opening it were you
help us out
could you bring anybody over there from
Birmingham
I was doing right well in Birmingham
because the car industry had just taken
off there
gambling had just been allowed so there
were casinos betting shops all that kind
of thing so I said yeah I said if I can
help so I started taking people over to
our Gamble and they did very well and it
authored back to the craze
they knew people who were clever they
knew people who were devious they knew
everything they knew if there was a
robbery there they knew who'd done it no
matter where we went
the people who were doing the moving
were people like Charlie
and a couple of the other lads
they were the ones who who moved out of
London the Twins were stuck in the East
End
they weren't interested in the bright
lights they wanted the bright lights to
come at them but they were pleased I was
taking people over there who had money
and could do stuff
and everything worked out fine then I'd
have a drink with them I'd go down the
SIM
and they were always always really
polite and I remember they said to me
Chris we got a problem
won the lads it was very very well known
God Rest his soul a good bloke
uh
is in jail
and his misses are having it with
somebody on Romford Market
um yeah what's the problem
well it's got to be sorted
he wants him up he doesn't want him dead
so okay
it's going to be dumb and I went to walk
away and Ronnie Craig said to me Chris
he said
I've got something for you and he gave
me a watch
and it was solid gold Waltham which
they'd bought out a watch as a
Piccadilly
can I just ask what the the difference
between the personalities of Ronnie and
Reggie was
Reggie was somebody who was quite deep
emotionally deep
his fault was he was a drinker was on
gin all the time and taking speed
he he came to me one day and he said
Chris he said look that girl we said you
were with you or used to be with he said
um
I like her he said could I talk to her
he didn't he didn't just go and talk to
her he came and asked me was it all
right
and I said yeah I said she's three or
three I'm no longer with her she's a
nice person you know get together if
that's what you want
Ronnie was a different kind of the fish
altogether
Ronnie was somebody I mean in the films
you've got this party animal
for a shootout
nothing like that
they was like more diplomatic than that
but all the time the diploma the
diplomacy was another thing he was
looking out of his lenses on underneath
her feet thinking yeah
paranoid you know what are you at I want
to find out and the only way I'm going
to find out is not by shouting at you
not by bullying you not being a nice
person
it's always nice to be nice it don't
cost nothing
it can be quite rewarding and that was
Ronnie Craig's attitude
but deep down was just tormented
demonized man
when he didn't take his medication
he was off the Spectrum he was off the
roof
and you never knew what was going to
happen and invariably Ronnie and Reggie
having a fight
and Charlie cray trying to separate him
because of any of the firm or anybody
else got involved they're starting to
mend a pair of them so you couldn't you
couldn't win my relationship was always
good with them to be honest with you I
presented no threat to them I presented
somebody who could help him and I
remember Ronnie saying to me one day
he said Chrissy said if anybody ever
touch regime
he said I've
put a dynamite jacket on
as a detonators ready he said I'd like
him and I'd walk amongst that right
amongst them and I'd blow the law and he
meant it
he meant it he would be prepared to die
for his brother and it was reversed the
same thing
went to a club called the dolls Club in
Birmingham
uh and a guy called Ray Mills a very
good friend Jason lad said to me Chris
he said we're going down I'm going down
to London tomorrow but he had come down
he said I've never met your brother Tony
and you've never met my brother Alan
yeah just come down and say hello
and uh met him and we drive down to
London
then we came over to the East End
and we went to a pub on the bathroom
Green Road and their mother was in there
old Charlie and the family and the firm
and we had a nice drink and everybody
was polite and everything went well
and Tony said let's go to the Regency
Club he said the Middlesbrough had never
been there I said I want to go to the
the region so it's Saturday night
gangsters there
sadly I relented Norwin
and uh when we go there
there's a room that goes around there's
a party and Jack make that he comes up
to me who I like Jack Jack the Hat was a
local Criminal
and people likes him I mean is it fun
kind of character when he lost it he
could be quite nasty
but all I ever saw of Jack Jack was a
fun guy
and he come up and said there's a party
guy and he said are you coming I said
what part he said blonde carols my car
outside the Regency Club this must be
about sort of our past 12 at night
is locked in by other cars there were a
lot of people there
and Jackson will go in my car and we
went to every Road
we get out of the car
I got into and he goes in
The Mills Brothers and Jack comes in
Jack runs into the room shouting out
where's the birds where's the party
where's the music and when it was all
playing and what people there dancing
and what have you
and uh
a scuffle started an argument
also didn't come down if it is
I came out for for a drink
anyway Ronnie Craig came out he said
what's the matter
see Chris said he didn't come down here
but it's a requested drop him off home
because I did quite a lot to drink
behind you know
and I didn't like it I didn't like what
was happening anyway
I saw a gun come out
but the gun didn't work so it was a
frighten as far as I could see anyway a
man called Connie White had took me home
I'm sitting at home
and I'm thinking well Tony is there and
my car's up there
you know I'm sobering up now I've had a
coffee and what have you with my dad
and I called a cab well
run down and got in a cab and went up to
Regency Club and got my car and then
drove around to the uh
to every Road
but I'd also got a gun
just in case anything had happened it's
only
and I went and knocked on the door
and Ronnie Bender came in the door
I said Saturday down there Ron he said
no Chris he said it's gone
and I said all right we're going to see
you later when I walked away said Don't
Leave Me
now we're talking about a regular
Soldier
a good guy
you know guy didn't fry an easy or
anything
and I said
Ronnie what do you mean don't leave you
he said they've killed him
I said what could we do he said kill
jacket
I said no no no not in a million years
not in front of a load of people like
that
that's impossible
I said where are they
he said never run away
I said a nephew
and what's your instructions
that they want me to take the body
carry out to the Railway Bridge and
Chuck it over the bridge so that it can
get messed up by a train
I said you mean to tell me that you have
got to carry a dead body the blood's
still coming out of it
I said and and you are actually going to
throw it over a Railway Bridge to get to
the Railway Bridge you've got to walk
100 yards
you can't do it he said please Chris
help me
so I thought everybody's dessert you've
got nobody
you know you you're a decent man if if
you ask me if I asked you for help you'd
help me I know that
so I went in
and we walked downstairs
and I walked in the front room and
there's a body line there
which krayton had had killed him Reggie
it was Reggie and Reggie wasn't
on the surface a violent man
always polite always thoughtful
always a good character
treated people nicely
what he did in quiet was a totally
different thing
so I said with Ronnie bend the wind
downstairs
and I realized Jack I had been murdered
I walked into the kitchen and there was
a basket of washing up the washing stuff
clothing and I looked through it and I
found some socks
I'll give Ronnie Bender a pair and I
took a pair and we put them on our hands
we couldn't have gloves
nobody was expecting to go in to that
kind of situation
and we went around and we tidied
everything up
I went upstairs to the bedroom
so I got an idea down off the bed
I took it downstairs and Ronnie bender
and I had managed to get Jack on into
the on the outside of down and we
wrapped him up
and we tidied everything up around
obviously blood stains on the carpet we
managed to get a knife and cut the
carpet up and what have you
and
we
we did the best we could
in the meantime and not came at a door
my brother Tony came looking for me
and he found saw my car outside
and he was involved and then again
another knock on the door
it's blonde Carroll
she's come back to her flat with her
boyfriend
George
and I'm carrying up a bucket
full of blood
in the you know with
a clutch where we've been cleaning up
to put down a toilet which was on the
next floor
and Carol came in and she said what's
happening Chris where's the party I said
no it's over
I said but there's been one or two
problems I want you to go in your
bedroom and don't come out until I tell
you
we're downstairs we're running bender
and Tony we managed to get the body
in the either down up the stairs and
into the hallway
it certainly weren't going in my car
but we actually wanted to get him into
Jack's own car people say they put a
dead body in the boot of a kite it's
impossible
so we've got Jack in the book in in the
back seat of the car
laid him out there and then there's an
argument Ronnie Bender said I'm not
driving that car
and he was adamant he was not going to
drive it
I couldn't drive it because I'm driving
my own car
and Tony said I'll do it
believe me that took some guts to turn
around and say you're gonna drive a dead
body
went outside we followed Tony
we followed him down a Mastery and then
a police car pulled out in front of Tony
I think please don't stop
please don't stop I don't want to do it
but if you stop my brother
and there's a body in the car
he's going to be a crucial murder he
didn't commit and everything else on it
and I'm gonna have to shoot you
to get him away
and that's that that's The Madness of it
all is there any sanity in it there is
no Sunny throughout the whole situation
anyway
the police car turned off thank God
and when we went down the Journey Down
The Mayor Street and kept on until we
got the Blackwood tunnel
we lost Tony and we were driving round
streets looking for him and eventually
we saw him and he was outside of church
the card ran out of petrol outside of
church
and there'd been a wedding there that
day because they were all kind of
petals and all the rest of it
and I thought well somebody will find it
that's the end of it as far as I'm
concerned you know we've got it off our
manner it's kind of
away from everybody somebody will come
to church or whatever they come out have
a look in the car see her body call the
police
so there's been an argument in South
London
it's definitely not East London
I looked in the paper the next day
nothing at all
for radio nothing at all
so what the hell's going on there
I don't know
that the craze have got in touch with
their brother Charlie
and got in touch with uh Freddie Foreman
and uh and drag them into it
so we are really talking about sensible
people here very clever criminals
masterminds
of criminal intelligence
and all this has gone on
total total chaos total total insanity
total Madness
and I thought
everybody will keep quiet there'd be no
no problems nobody's going to say
anything
uh and the next thing
was
they all got arrested more or less all
at once all the firm but Ronnie Bender
tyranny myself no
so everything was kind of safe
and then what happened was that uh
I was arrested at Arts Hotel no I wasn't
I was arrested outside the uh a
nightclub there
and
um I was driving down towards the Elbow
Room
and they surrounded me Paul Shooters out
put your hands on top of the car which I
did they take me to inside your house on
the embankment
and I thought we would probably go to
Scotland Yard it wasn't that at all
and they kind of
went in I went into a room they took me
in this room and there's photographs of
the craze and all their colors are all
there
and um
he said you want to tell us about it I
said tell you about what
they said they're making murder I said I
don't know what you're talking about
they said you were there but you left
I said no I don't know I honestly do not
know what you're talking about murder no
and they said look we do know and we
know you had nothing to do is tell us
about it and neither Yoon or none of
your family will be arrested
I said I don't know what you're talking
about they were loyal to me and I was
Lord with them some of them got Nick
they never put me away
and I certainly wasn't going to put
anybody else away
whether it was a craze or anybody else
you don't say anything you don't stand
in the dock and point your finger at
people
that's the rule of law in the East End
it always has been it probably always
will be amongst the growing Generations
anyway he let me go nipple Reed and he
said look there's my card ring me
I'm here to help you
instead of walking away just forgetting
it all
I went and saw Mrs Gray
I went a bunny or row knocked on the
door Violet invited me in and there was
a guy called Caroline there with him
with a with a family
and I said look the police have arrested
me but they they brought me down to
London I've been to a place called
tintage House believe me there's a lot
going on they've got boards full of
connections and everything else with the
twins up there and it's not looking good
and she said Chris do as a favor
their friends have desired them please
please will you not just come and tell
them what you told me
I said I can't do it Wanda it's too
dodgy she went please Chris you're the
only one who can help him will you just
come and tell him
I went to Brixton
went in
give a moody name
and Charlie cray sees me and he goes
Chris shouldn't be
I said I can't help but I said your mom
wanted me to come over just say hello to
twins
you shouldn't be here and I went over I
spoke to him oh they're overjoyed
and I told him what had happened they
said Chris
don't worry about anything it's all
sorted you know
just make sure people are not talking
but then went back to my normal life
thinking everything's going to be smooth
it's okay there's a criminal masterminds
you know they've got connections
everywhere police you name it MPS all
the rest of it nothing's going to happen
but uh
it did happen
nipple Reed kind of got me in Birmingham
again
brought me down to London
why did you go to uh Brixton prison with
Violet crying Charlie cray
you were there
I said yeah I went to say hello
you don't say hello I told you I was
trying to help you
I told you you had nothing to do with
this
and that's what we've got
now tell us about it what happened I
said oh no don't know what you're
talking about you're talking a load of
rubbish
no I'm not talking and I infuriated him
that much
they he was playing around with a gun on
his desk and he ran around the table and
he smashed me over there with a gun
you don't want to tell me what happened
he said
charge him with murder
and that was Frank cater that the other
superintendent
and I thought murder
and cater went murder
he said yeah if he wants to be with a
craze he wants to keep shut on it let
him be with him let him do the time with
him
and they charged me with murder
they then took me to Bow Street police
station
and I'm in Bow Street and I can hear
voices
and then I recognized one as Ronnie
bender and the other one was my brother
Tony they had been arrested as well
and we're going to stand in the dock
and I look in the dock
that's myself
there's Tony
Ronnie Bender Reggie Ronnie Freddie
Foreman Charlie cray
we sit in that dock
a one after another he saw the cry firm
getting up and giving evidence not
against me
not against Sony no against Ronnie
Bender
against the cray twins
it started off with the craze going up
and they got 30 each
which they kind of expected
and then Ronnie Bender went up and he
got light and 20.
me and Tony went up and we got life in
15.
Freddie foreman and and Charlie crane
went up they got their tens
uh Connie White it went up and got seven
it the uh in Barry got 25.
what did the Christ do they throw all
their friends to the walls
did they stand up and say no them people
shouldn't be doing time
we're the ones who should be doing time
they didn't commit any murder no they
didn't no everybody goes down the Drone
and so that was it it was it was a
travesty of Justice
it's all
it's all Fantasy A lot of the stuff
I'm sorry to say you know the cry Empire
well I mean they were all skimped when
they died
the englishes weren't paid the full
money I saw I believe for the funerals
we'll have a look at Ronnie Christ here
and all the cars and everything else
like that
where did they get the money to pay for
that they didn't have it someone told me
the other day that they had a formal
empowermention no they didn't
it was somebody else's
their mum and dad lived in a council
flat in Bunnell row
I'd reached a stage where I couldn't
cope anymore I wanted to kill myself
or killer screw because that way I could
justify being in prison
I hadn't killed anybody why am I doing a
life sentence and all the rest of it
and I thought don't think like this
you've got to get your head on straight
you've got to find something to get you
through this
and under my bed
there were some books that a guy called
Stewart Brown had left good panamine
and I went through them and there was
philosophy there was crime there was
this that and the other you know all
kinds of books and there was a Bible
so I opened the Bible and that was the
front door
and he came into my life and I've been
blessed
I've got lovely children that have got
University degrees
I'm blessed that I've got many many good
friends who've helped me have been there
for me because you've got to understand
that our man suffers in jail
I mean that jail can be very nasty but a
man in prison deals with reality a day
at a time
he begins to understand what love is he
understands what loneliness is he
understands what pain is Disappointment
but if your mind is focused on drugs
we're focused on money you don't see
nothing else
you're blind
and there is none so blind as them that
cannot see
and there was nobody more Blinder than
me when I'm at The Craze
I should have walked away here
because I know it wasn't a good thing
and it weren't going to end well
he went what's going on I said tomorrow
I'll sit at seven o'clock in the morning
go and get Kennedy that was my sign off
shotgun it was named after prison
Kennedy I said I want one chamber one
back shot filled with rock salt and the
other one with the normal bloodshot you
know right yeah I'm not missing a bet
with these people they're dangerous I'm
going to shoot them